and new tonight court records show that  prosecutors plan to seek the death  penalty against a man accused of several  recent murders police say DNA evidence  linked 19-year-old Alonzo Brown to those  crimes he's accused of killing three men  between January and June of this year  our 8 news now investigators were the  only ones to talk to him from behind  bars investigator David charns mentioned  the possibility of the death penalty in  that interview but throughout the  conversation Brown maintained his  innocence  it's strange because why would an 18  year old kid who has nothing beside your  speed  y wake up one day and say  you're telling me that you are not the  person who killed these three men  no sir I'm not so Brown will be in court  December 2nd for a competency hearing  you can see the rest of our interview on  our website at 8newsnow.com